when I tatted my face as a grown man my
mama SLA me like your face too beautiful
son and you going to mess it up she like
you think you grown you think you just
cuz you grown like M grown as hell like
she was mad about that
sh oh my first face T I got was across I
got that in jail too on some crazy
like hitting my with a uh like one
by one like like a you know a charger
box it's like something in the inside
they made it out of that so it just go
slow like that sh hurt so bad my face
was big as hell when I got that
done too and I had to get it redone cuz
it fade it started fading on me I got my
daughter's name on my face on the
biggest hell on my face I got my son
named Cody on my face I got an angel
playing a guitar I got my grandama name
on my face what else I got on my face I
got 100 right here got to keep it a 100
D I got blessed over my eyebrow yeah I
probably got like 10 on my face though
goop and Lil Wayne first rappers I seen
with face tattoo I was a big goop fan
like Gucci fan and Wayne you know T
really gave us the game he was starting
to hit the face crazy and it was like we
got to hit the face I'm I'm going do
that admit that that's no
cap I got a hand with the globe in the
inside of it and it say The World Is
Mine around around the front I got my
girl's name on my neck I got pop girls
on my neck this my girl favorite cartoon
look character I got a dove bird on my
neck that's it for the
neck what was the first tattoo I ever
got was well I got like a couple at one
time so my Xbox I got my MMA name I got
my Grandmama name and I got my
granddaddy name cuz I all I feel like
when they see it I got your name at
least I got your name but yeah it was
like three of my homeboy we got tattoo
the dude tat us up he gave us enough for
us to get like two three a piece names
though I started at 14 but by like 15 I
started going crazy 16 the next big one
I got it was this big uh of bra a right
here on my left arm that was the biggest
one I got after that and then I just
started going crazy like I was addicted
then it was like damn I need to get a
tattoo every week you know you young I
was young too so I was like 15 16 they
weren even good either I like I be mad
now that I got him so early I was trying
to be on some cool really you know
how it be I got my first tattoo I'm like
oo I just kept going crazy I got these
ass alien spaceships it look
like a 10y old boy Droid I got my
brother name and my older brother name
but you can't see it cuz it ink faded I
ain't never retouch it up I got a lot of
I got the Gucci G's and they
all different shapes size they supposed
to be the Gucci G's my homeboy stole his
mama laptop right and we thinking he
didn't came up on the laptop and when he
steal a laptop he sells the laptop for
the tattoos I'm in there talking about
the laptop on the phone like I think I'm
talking to A- my boy A- like bro we just
got tatted he like what y'all do I'm
like yeah we had a little silver laptop
man this man his mom was right there he
like no no no no his mama like you stole
my K both of us out the
crib K both of us out the crib and then
I was like bro that's crazy bro you
set me up he like why you say something
I'm like you stealing from your
mama it's crazy yeah that was a crazy
time I got viril RP my brother V man I
got viril on my in C I got the movie
Dead prisoners when they got the white
paint on their face and they robbing the
banks I got Bas out on my right leg I
got Malcolm X when he looking out the
window with the shotgun I have all my
kids faces on the back of my legs I got
five kids so I got all their faces on
the back of my my legs I got Michael
Jackson on this left leg I got my
favorite cartoon freakazoid I got Call's
dolls I got tekashi mirami pillow on the
kneecap I got the Eiffel Tower on my
face cuz my friend Paris he got killed
but I got his face tatted right here too
though I got the night for Christmas
that's one of my favorite movies tatt on
my leg I got the demon like the Dodge
Demon cuz I'm a big dodge fan no
rats so I got a dude like showing this
grill with rolling stone across the top
I got Frankenstein I Ted on my thigh
yeah that's all the leg tat I got
Thriller Michael Jackson right here this
still Thriller Michael Jackson too but
that's when regular so it's the
transformation it's theti good and the
bad you dig and then I got Scarface
holding the stick big as hell right here
I got Tessy Chainsaw Massacre Michael
Myers damn what else I got I got M Mo
across my chest I got a angel holding
the chopper on this side and I got like
a skeleton holding a 38 special on this
side this was a cover up cuz this tattoo
was trash can juice I had like two money
bags and for the smoke he was supposed
to do smoke but he did like some swirly
between the bags l c look like
it was some clouds I got it covered up
with the with the angel with the stick
and the skeleton with 38 Special you got
dou 7 also are you a James Bond fan yes
sir before I was playing Call of Duty I
was playing
[Music]
007 so for the back piece you know I got
my brother take on there I just cover my
whole back with him cuz I feel like he
just got my back it was kind of like my
M to myself that's with the kids too you
know I feel like all my meaningful
though all my tattoos are meaningful I
remember all the times I was getting it
and how it meant to me during the time I
got a lot of people that mean a lot to
me tatted on me the takeoff piece on my
back took 8 hours one session were you
out for that like what was that
experience I was out I'm out for all my
sessions you know you got to get in that
zone man that's a long time to get
tatted though you know I'm tell you the
worst pain most painful ones though is
the
thighs when I got out of it I had to go
wheelchair s couldn't really sit down
I'm in the car like trying not to sit
down that hurt like in the inner
thighs and it stayed swoll for so long
like I woke up and this was just
like red on fire I was scared a little I
had to call the tattoo I was like bro he
like oh yeah yo your inner thigh so
sensitive it ain't never doing nothing
it don't never have no action the
outside of your legs get action lay down
fall but right there usually don't never
get touched like it's like hot water
getting on your back when you get in the
shower so it's real sensitive that
had my SW yeah I ain't going to lie
I don't know man that behind that
kneecap too that hurt too cuz the
healing process hurts I was like trying
to keep my just straight in the bed
then like when you hit them legs it's
like when you stand up all your blood
just be rushing to the bottom that
be hurting for a little
minute